I'm Andrew Trask, the programs lead instructor.
I'm also the author of "Grokking Deep Learning".
I'm a researcher at Deep Mind and at Oxford University,
where I'm pursuing my PhD focused on deep learning and privacy.
I'm also the leader of open-mind.org,
an open-source community of over 3,000 AI researchers and
developers who are dedicated to building technology for safe AI.
Data privacy has been a very important concern for government and companies these days.
It gives rise to a very interesting challenge,
since on one hand,
we are pushing further and further for high-quality models and accessible data,
but on the other hand,
we need to keep data safe from both intentional and accidental leakage.
When doing artificial intelligence in the real world,
you'll find that most datasets are siloed within large enterprises for two reasons.
First, enterprises have a legal risk which
prevents them from wanting to share their data set outside of their organization.
Secondly, enterprises have a competitive advantage to
hang on to large datasets collected from or about their customers.
This leads to one very challenging consequence.
Scientists like us are often extremely constrained
in terms of the amount of data they have access to to solve their problems.
This challenge is quietly holding back research
across society and nearly every person facing industry,
making it more challenging to cure disease or understand complex societal trends.
The biggest tragedy of the situation is that the more personal to
data and the more personal the potential uses of that data in society,
the more restricted it is from scientists.
This means that some of
the most important and personal issues in
society simply cannot be addressed with machine learning,
because we do not have access to the proper training data.
But by learning how to do machine learning that protects privacy,
you can make a huge difference in humanity's ability to make progress,
curing disease, and truly understanding who we are through our data.
I will be teaching you state of the art techniques for privacy preserving
artificial intelligence such as Federate Learning and differential privacy,
so that you can get hands-on practice building your own private AI models.
I am super excited to go with you in this journey
and I hope you're as excited as I am. Let's get to it.